vous allez faire une petite
démonstration d'accord devant alizé est
votre partenaire vous avez choisi
isabelle morini bosc et ben écoutez
[Applaudissements]
allez on va aller on va te suit de
recevoir jeanine newton john attention
c'est parti vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez après c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont
sur la tête de ma mère
mais non mais en fait parce que toujours
la même danse nommé le refrain est le
refrain barils à la fracture dans la
chorégraphie
il ya une fracture oui non ir et rend
une vous allez vous pétez un truc non
mais parce que quelques petites bêtes
dont j'ai passé à ça de ma mère assad ma
mère m'a météo train à chaud je
comprends rien allez on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand
entrée dans la troupe la donzelle couple
qui sera le meilleur grise grise le
musical au théâtre mogador aller les
voir ils sont exceptionnels vraiment je
vous kiffe un je vous kiffe tous alors
je oui mais moi aussi ma mère ou là bas
c'était boulami il est parti deux fois
avec une amie star et qu'elle serait
plus jamais revu sa deuxième coupe c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
canada
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement profite pour remercier les
kurdes aux frontières c'est moi il ya
une fenêtre à remettre julien je te
trouve magnifique ah mais je te jure tu
m'a impressionné ouais mais je te jure
je ne savais pas que julien fabuleux
france mof franchement julien vous étiez
formidable là les deux alors autant tout
à l'heure ce que j'ai vu c'est l
escalade de l'horreur qu'est ce qu'il a
gagné l'écrabouiller maxime si je me
sentais si ça vient avec isabelle morini
bosc
[Applaudissements]
julien c'est un amour c'est julien parce
qu'il donne de sa personne il veut bien
essayer avec isabelle morini bosc pour
voir si le partenaire arrive à sublimer
la personne
regardez isabelle morini-bosc mes années
en tout cas vous cette coiffure vous va
très bien non mais jamais pour une après
je peux aller chez michou un merci à
l'est alesis impartie palaiseau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça va mal à mon bébé via l'
attention attention on va tout lui péter
au matin du fait qu'ils observeront java
ma chérie ça va bien ah ouais elle a
adoré julien c'est vrai merci attention
troisième et dernier couple je crois
qu'on a
jean michel vernhes j'ai pas d'avenir
accompagné de quelqu'un qui aime la
danse par dessus tout si les initiales
sont les mêmes qu american airlines un
gâteau proulx c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marca c'est qu'avant voile et cdh a
soulevé et la fenps en laisse tomber
j'ai jeté un coup adams est un vélo
d'olt ces conneries jean michel et
agathe vraiment ouais et je sais qu'à
gâte
vous avez a été contre votre nature
donné c'est à dire ça alors mettez bien
votre micro ce que je me permettais mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec vous avant parce
que c'est pas ça viendra où elle déteste
dans ces agapes l addition je n'en avais
pas je le sais vous êtes un petit peu
dans l'émission chinon mais je ne sais
pas qui n'aimait pas danser vous écoutez
vos camarades accord est en tout cas
vous vous non pour moi je vais vous dire
le meilleur couple
le public a voté mais d'abord vous c'est
qui à quoi
lire à ce que vous y connaissez pas en
sensualité d'ailleurs faux et d'ailleurs
vous ans en rigolant dirait nicolas
sirkis d'indochine rennes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la hauteur du lourd vous ont jamais
fait rien à voir
merci
merci à celui qui a trahi son mari n'a
qu'à oui c'est vrai et oui celui qu'il
attrape son mari oui voilà vous allez
vous marier avant la fin de l'année non
mais
[Applaudissements]
les séries jouent à dire franchement je
crois qu'elle une admission dans le
sondage twitter on va voir les gens ont
voté pour qui pour nous ici c'est qu'est
dit julien courbet maxime bah oui c'est
kelly julien courbet bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]